little nas x makes out with his backup
dancer
we're here we're getting used to it the
singer took the stage at the 2021 bet
awards on sunday night for a steamy
rendition of his hit song
montero call me by your name
[Music]
it's pride month happy pride month well
nas x took on the role of a
pharaoh in an egyptian themed
performance that paid direct homage to
michael jackson's remember the time
music video
on the phone doing me
till dawn two three what about us
girl
[Applause]
[Music]
accompanied by a set of all-male dancers
the singer took his throne before ending
the performance with a passionate kiss
e.t spoke with lilna's ex on the red
carpet ahead of the show
and he did not mince words about what he
had prepared
performance i can't give you much but
it's going to be the best one
the chart-topping hit was released back
in march causing a mix of praise and
controversy for its music video in which
he gives the devil a lap dance
[Music]
did it trip you out a little bit with
the all the pushback that came back with
montero and the shoes and all that
were you like what's going on y'all just
relax i thought it was way more
than i would have believed that it would
be i mean you know but that's
life we got to push it forward we got to
keep going
[Music]
you